Selena Gomez's mother breaks her silence
on her transplant surgery as her
daughter's kidney donor Francia is
spotted out for the first time my wife
and my family and friends I'm just a
really happy place it's been good
Selena's mom mandy is breathing a sigh
of relief after the pop star went under
the knife for her lupus this summer she
posted this pic of Selena and her bestie
on Thursday and opened up about what the
scary experience was like as a parent
[Music]
she wrote quote for all those moments of
not knowing if we were going up or going
down
I can always come back to this picture
mandy admits she felt helpless and
scared in the hospital but she was still
able to pray adding quote Selena gained
a kidney I was able to keep my little
girl but I also gained another daughter
meanwhile Francia was seen out and about
in LA on Friday after the transplant
news broke here's the actress looking
carefree and healthy while walking
around the set of her show groaning
you